-Welcome to the show.
And also welcome to NBC.
-Thank you.
I'm so thrilled to be here.
You have no idea.
-You have been called the
Godfather of Fantasy Football,
and you've done
a lot of cool things.
I think one of
the coolest things is that
you helped a lot of the Avengers
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
play fantasy football.
And, in fact, they liked you
so much that you're in --
-I was texting with
Chris Pratt today.
He wants to know Elijah Mitchell
or Rashaad Penny Week 1.
Elijah Mitchell is the answer.
-Wow.
-I'm just saying.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-Well, here you are in
a pretty massive scene of
"Avengers: Endgame."
This is Robert Redford, you,
Robert Downey Jr.,
and Chris Hemsworth.
And did you --
I'm not being rude.
Did you have
a speaking line in the --
-I had four lines,
believe it or not.
Like, no,
when you watch it, Jimmy,
when you watch it back,
because I know that's what
you're going to do tonight,
just put on the closed caption.
I'm only on camera
for one of them.
Three big stars.
But I got four lines.
I'm in the cast.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-So IMDb, you're in the cast?
-I'm in the cast.
I'm part of the MCU. I'm canon.
I have my own page
on the Marvel Wiki.
Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-That's fantastic.
Is that your only film
you've been in?
-Yes, it is.
And, by the way,
so, "Avengers: Endgame,"
as you guys know,
is the highest-grossing movie
of all time worldwide, okay?
And it's the only movie
I have been in.
So, I mean, people want to talk
about Tom Cruise or The Rock
and their total box office,
but I'm just saying,
if you look at the stats,
which is what I do,
on a per-movie basis,
I'm the highest-grossing actor
of all time worldwide.
-Oh, my gosh. It's amazing.
-Numbers are numbers.
-I'm just saying.
I've retired from movies.
I'm never going to do it.
So until some movie beats
"Avengers: Endgame,"
like, I'm the guy.
-Yeah. I wanted to talk to you
about fantasy football
and when it got popular
and did you ever see yourself
as being the top analyst or
even having a career
based on fantasy football
when you were a kid?
-No. You know, I do
these interviews sometimes,
and people say like,
"Oh, is this your dream job?"
I'm like, "No."
When I was dreaming of jobs,
this didn't exist.
You know what I mean?
Like, fantasy football
was like a sports version
of "Dungeons & Dragons."
Like, it was this
nerdy, niche thing.
And so the idea that I could
somehow make a living
wearing makeup, being on TV,
talking about fake football
was, you know, asinine to me.
And, you know, so, the fact that
I was in "Avengers: Endgame,"
the fact that I'm
on "The Tonight Show" --
I'm on the "The Tonight Show
with Jimmy Fallon."
What's better than that?
-Yeah.
-I mean, right?
-No, I'm happy.
-This is cool.
-I'm happy --
Now, also, you're involved --
You're part of
"Football Night in America."
You're on the team
now here at NBC.
So now, yeah,
we share the same locker room.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, so, but
after the show, weirdly,
tonight,
"The Tonight Show" staff --
we're all getting together.
We're doing
the fantasy-football draft.
I have no idea what I'm doing.
-Okay. I can help.
This is what I do.
-Yeah.
-We're colleagues now.
-You can e-mail me.
-I can?
-I'll get my number to you.
You'll text me. Yeah.
Wait. 'Cause, listen, it's
"The Tonight Show
with Jimmy Fallon" League.
Jimmy Fallon can't finish last.
We can't have you
doing some sort of punishment
or anything like that.
Like, I feel like we need to get
you to the playoffs,
but not win.
Like, so you look good,
but you don't crush
staff morale.
-Oh, yeah, I understand.
-You're the star.
-Yeah, yeah, you're very smart.
-Yeah, you don't want me
to win...
-Right, right.
-...but just get far enough
to show that I could win.
-Exactly. You could win,
and you're just
sort of taking it easy.
-Just for anyone watching,
the first one,
everyone's like,
"Oh, you got to get..."
-Right. Well, so, I know --
I talked to
your producer backstage.
You have the second pick.
You have pick 2 this year.
-I have pick 2. That's big deal.
-Right. So, most likely,
Jonathan Taylor will go 1.
He's the Colts' running back,
had a great season last year.
So, my question to you is,
what kind of player are you?
Like, do you want to be
risk-averse
or are you gonna
swing for the fences?
Because I'm a believer in,
you know,
Ricky Bobby from
"Talladega Nights."
Like, if you ain't first,
you're last, right?
If I were you, at pick 2,
I'm taking Christian McCaffrey,
who's been hurt
the last two years,
but, when he is healthy,
has been the best player
in fantasy football.
So, again,
it's a risk/reward pick.
That's what I would do at 2.
That's who I have
ranked number 2.
-Now, when you
say things like this,
does it throw the numbers,
like, crazy?
Maybe.
-Somewhat.
Yeah, I mean, I don't know.
You know, yes.
I mean, I'm flattered that a lot
of people pay attention to
what I say.
-So you can make up a name.
You're like, "Oh,
you got to get Skip Benson."
-Right. Yeah.
-And you go, "Who's that?"
-Dougle McGillicuddy at
running back is a sleeper.
Yeah, but most -- In the
fantasy-football industry,
most people have McCaffrey
at number 2 or 1.
Yeah. So that's not
a controversial take by me.
-So, you will help me out?
-I will help you out.
I've got your back.
By the way, do you want to win?
I mean, like, you can --
Because, like, yeah,
I mean, if you want to,
I will help you
crush your staff like a grape.
You know, let's do it.
-Yes! Yes!
-Like, I was trying to be nice.
-That's what I'm talking about.
I'm taking out Kamal.
I'm taking Kamal out.
Matthew Berry,
I appreciate you, buddy.
-Hey, thanks for having me,
Jimmy.
-Thanks for being here.
-My pleasure.
-Matthew Berry.
Watch "Fantasy Football
Happy Hour" weekdays on Peacock.